when I came to America I had to close on
everything and start from scratch yeah
so now I was like I have to ask billel
for everything that I want until I get
my business up and running
okay that's you I'll say the ugly word
that's
you're younger than me you know imagine
if you're my age and having to ask your
husband for everything because he leave
me totally out of his finances I don't
know how much money he makes
recently that was like well you know
what I think we should have a joint bank
account you know we are married we want
to go in business together and he was
like hold up no
so
wait you ask him to have a joint bank
account and he was not thinking that's a
good idea no he was like why I always
said I want to have a joint back
yeah
this is pissing me off right now you
know why because you sharing the bed
together yeah and like what he doesn't
trust you with his bank account that's
like that's really crazy to me you know
girl I'm looking on it I'm I'm
definitely working on it we'll see
that's a big thing to hide you know like
when you hide in your bank account you
basically hide anything
now you have me thinking like you could
be doing anything you can with his money
like because I don't have any access to
it and I don't know anything about it
as an other girlfriend that he buy her
flight tickets to go somewhere and she
will never know because she can't even
check the bank account like that's a big
trust issue what is your point why you
are hiding she don't need to like sit at
home and let her husband to control her
and all of her finances she need to be
in control
so if he's not sharing much information
when it comes to his finances I wonder
what secrecy does he have that's not
normal
I'm realizing that I need to Stand My
Ground and start speaking up for myself
so I'm looking forward to this tunnel
[Music]